[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهداء فالوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من رام الله والتوتر المتصاعد بين
الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين لا سيما في بلده
حواره جنوبيه نابلس في الضفه الغربيه
قتلان في صفوف المستوطنين واعتداءات عديده
ومتكرره ضد الفلسطينيين
في موسكو جدد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اتهامه للغرب قائلا ان هدفه الوحيد
هو تفكيك روسيا والسيطره عليها وان وقوف
الدول الاوروبيه مع الولايات المتحده لا
يصب في مصلحه الاوروبيين
تاتينا هذه الصور من واشنطن حيث قال
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان الصين
تدرك مدى التكلفه التي سيتعين عليها دفعها
في حال قدمت اسلحه لروسيا في حربها على
اوكرانيا
في مواضيع الحصاد
تصعيد في الضفه وتفاهمات في العقبه
مستوطنون يقتلون فلسطينيا يحرقون منازل في
نابلس ويعتدون على الطواقم الطبيه وفرق
الدفاع المدني وفرق الدفاع المدني بعد
مقتل مستوطنين اثنين في حواره باطلاق نار
الاحتلال يشدد الاجراءات الامنيه في الضفه
الغربيه وحكومته توسع الاجراءات
الانتقاميه
وفي تفاهمات العقبه وبعد التزامات
فلسطينيه اسرائيليه بخفض التصعيد والعنف
وتعليق مؤقت لاجراءات الاحاديه والانشطه
الاستيطانيه الجديده نتنياهو يقول ان
البناء الاستيطاني وتشريع البؤر
الاستيطانيه لن يتوقفاه واشنطن وعمان
والقاهره تتحدث عن خطوات لبناء الثقه
والفصائل تحذر من توفير غطاء لجرائم
الاحتلال
معارك السيطره تحتدم في محيط مدينه مخموت
الاستراتيجيه الشرقيه اوكرانيا كيف تقول
ان الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات من الشركاء
الغربيين غير كافيه وتتوقع مواجهه صعوبات
ميدانيه في الربيع والصيف
وبوتين يقول ان روسيا في مواجهه فعليه مع
النيتو
وان الصراع يقتضي اخذ القدرات النوويه
لدول الحلف بعين الاعتبار
المتوسط يبتلع المزيد من الضحايا غداه
اعتماد روما قانونا يقيد عمليات الانقاذ
في البحر ويعرقل وصول الناجين لموانئها
غرقوا نحو 60 من طالبي لجوء بينهم اطفال
بعد تحطم مركبهم قباله سواحل ايطاليا
ودعوات اوروبيه لوضع قواعد جديده ومشتركه
لحل تعقيدات الهجره
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان البيان الختامي
الاجتماع العقبه ان الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي اكد التزامهما بخفض التصعيد
ومنع مزيد من العنف وبالعمل الفوري لوقف
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب لمده تتراوح بين
ثلاثه اشهر الى سته وفي غزه قالت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ان المشاركه الفلسطينيه في
اجتماع العقبه جريمه وطنيه لا يمكن السكوت
عليها وحذرت من تبعتها باستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم من المستفيد مما اسفر عنه
اجتماع العقبه من نتائج والتزامات
77% قالوا ان المستفيد هو الجانب
الاسرائيلي بينما قال سبعه في المئه فقط
ان الجانب الفلسطيني هو المستفيد وراى 16%
ان المستفيده اطراف اقليميه ودوريه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا وان نتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من الزلزال تحذيرات من
تفشي الكوليرا في شمال غربي سوريا بسبب
انهيار شبكات الصرف الصحي
ساعات قليله بعد الكشف عن التزامات
فلسطينيه اسرائيليه في اجتماع العقبه
بالتهدئه وخفض التصعيد تتسارع الاحداث في
الضفه الغربيه ويتسع مشهد التوتر فقد قتل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا بالرصاص
الحي جنوبي نابلس وتزامن ذلك مع احراق
مستوطنين منازل فلسطينيين ومحال تجاريه في
بلده حواره جنوبي نابلس كما اعلن الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني اصابه عشرات الفلسطينيين
جراء اعتداء المستوطنين عليهم في المنطقه
وسجل اعتداء على ثلاث سيارات اسعاف ومنع
طواقم صحفيه من تغطيه هذه الاعتداءات
حاره منازل حرق محلات الشارع
وين المكان وين مكان نار وين مكان حريق
وين مكان تدمير وين مكان تكسير
حاره منازل حرق
وبشره من رام الله ينضم الينا مراسل جزيره
سمير ابو شماله سمير اطلعنا على تطور
المواقف
نعم بدايه جلال قبل قليل اعلنت وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه عن استشهاد الشاب سامح
الاقطش الذي يبلغ من العمر 37 عاما وذلك
متاثرا بجروح اصيب بها خلال اعتداء جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين عليه في
قريه زعتر الواقع الجنوبي مدينه نابلس وقد
اضافت وزاره الصحه بان الشاب الاقطش هو قد
اصيب برصاصه في البطن ولم تتمكن الطواقم
الطبيه من قاضي حياته لانها كانت حالته
بالحرجان جدا هذا جاء بالتزامن مع استمرار
المجموعات من المستوطنين بالمئات قد
اقتحموا عدد من الشوارع والضواحي والاحياء
الواقعه الجنوبي مدينه نابلس وتحديدا في
بلده
حوار وقرى عينبوس وبيت فوريك والعديد من
المناطق الاخرى والتي من خلالها قد احرق
المستوطنون عشرات المنازل فلسطينيه
والمحال التجاريه وايضا احراق عدد كبير من
المركبات التابعه
للمدنيين الفلسطينيين خلال اقتحامهم
واعتدائهم على
الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم في تلك القرى
والبلدات جنوبي مدينه نابلس الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ذكر بانه قد تعاملت طواقمه مع
اكثر من 100 اصابه ما بين طعن بالسكين
بالسكاكين وايضا بالضرب والاختراق ايضا
بالغاز المسيل للدموع التي استخدمته قوات
الاحتلال ايضا قمع وتفريق المحتجين
والفلسطينيين الذين خرجوا للتصديت لهذه
الاعتداءات من قبل المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على الصعيد المواقف الرسميه
المؤسسه الرسميه الفلسطينيه المتمثله
بالرئاسه الفلسطينيه والحكومه والوزاره
وزاره الخارجيه قد ادانت هذه الاعتداءات
واعتبرت ان هذه الاعتداءات هي نابعه من
النهج الحكومه الاسطاليه المتطرفه وايضا
من خلال التصريحات
ارضيه والمواقف التحريضيه التي اطلقها
الكثير من المسؤولين في هذه الحكومه اتجاه
الفلسطينيين وايضا الدعوات للانتقام
لمقتل اثنين من المستوطنين في في بلده
حواره ظهره هذا اليوم من على يد مسلح
فلسطيني وهذه المواقف من قبل المؤسسه
الرسميه هي حملت الحكومه الاسرائيليه ايضا
بشكل مباشر عن تداعيات هذه
الاعتداءات وهذا النهج باتجاه الفلسطينيين
والاعتداءات المستمره بحقهم وايضا طلبت
المجتمع الدولي بمنظماته الحقوقيه
والانسانيه والسياسيه بضروره التدخل
الفوري والعاجل لتوفير الحمايه للشعب
الفلسطيني من هذه الاعتداءات هذه الاحداث
وهذه الاعتداءات وهذه التطورات الاخيره هي
جاءت عقب مقتل اثنين من المستوطنين على يد
مسلح فلسطيني شاب فلسطيني المسلح في بلده
حواره دور هذا اليوم وق تلى ذلك على
العديد من ردود الفعل من خلال اغلاق قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه العديد من الحواجز
العسكريه المؤديه الى مدينه نابلس وايضا
ملاحقه منفذ الهجوم وذلك في ظل التباين في
المواقف ايضا على ما جرى في قمه العقبه من
خلال مشاركه الوفد الفلسطينيه رسميا في
هذه القمه وادانه المواقف اداره الفصائل
لهذه المشاركه وذلك من خلال تقرير قد
اعددناه لرصد جميع المواقف المتباينه
وايضا هجوم بلده حواره التي وقع هذا اليوم
في التقرير التالي
هي عمليه لافته في توقيتها وسياقها اسفرت
عن مقتل مستوطنين على يد مسلح فلسطيني في
الشارع الرئيسي داخل بلده حوار جنولسن
العمليه تلاها سيل من ردود الفعل قوات
الاحتلال اغلقت مداخل المدينه وشرعت في
البحث عن منفذ الهجوم
ومستوطنون اعتدوا على فلسطينيين في بلدات
وقرى المجاوره للمستوطنات في نابلس فيما
طالب مسؤولون سياسيون ورؤساء تجمعات
الاستيطانيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه بسحب
وفدها من خدمه العقبه ردا على الاجتماع
الامن الخطير الفصائل الفلسطينيه التي
دانت عقب اجتماع طارئ لها في غزه مشاركه
مسؤولين فلسطينيين في قمه العقبه
واعتبرتها جريمه وطنيه لما تحمله من خطط
امريكيه تهدف الى وعد المقاومه بركه
العمليه ووصفتها بالنوعيه ورات فيها ردا
طبيعيا على الاحتلال ومستوطني الحاله
الفلسطينيه تتجه نحو التكاتف والتعاضد في
عمل وطني شعبي مقاوم ستستمر المقاومه على
الارض
يتم تفعيلها اكثر ردا على كل هذه
المؤامرات التي تجري لاضعاف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ومحاصرتها
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه التي شاركت في اجتماع
العقبه للمره الاولى منذ سنواته مع
مسؤولين اسرائيليين بحضور مصري واردني
ورعايه امريكيه اكدت التزامها بقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه لانهاء الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والمطالبه بوقف جميع الاجراءات
الاحاديه الجانب من سلطات الاحتلال اما
حركه فتح فشددت على موقفها الثابت من اي
تحرك يهدف الى نجم الاحتلال ووقف عدوانه
على الفلسطينيين اللقاء مع المجتمع الدولي
واللقاء مع في ظل طبعا وجود القياده
الاردنيه
والاشقاء المصريين هو امر مهم في حمايه
الشعب الفلسطيني من هذا الاحتلال وهذا
الامر لا يلغي ايضا الحراق الذي تقوم به
حركه فتح وتكون به الفصائل الفلسطينيه على
الارض في موضوع المقاومه الشعبيه وفي
موضوع التصدي للاحتلال والمستوطنين
هجوم حواره جاء في وقت تباينت فيه المواقف
بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه بشان قمه العقبه
لكن القاسم المشترك بينها كما تقول هو
نصره المقاومه باشكالها المختلفه لوقف
جرائم الاحتلال ومستوطنه التي وصفت بانها
الاكثر دمويه منذ بدايه هذا العام سمير
ابو شماله الجزيره رام الله فلسطين
شكرا لسمير في رام الله اذا في مدينه
العقبه الاردنيه اقر البيان الختابي
الاجتماعي الامني وسياسي التزام الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي بخفض التصعيد ومنع
العنف اضافه الى الحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي القائم في الاماكن المقدسه ونقلت
وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول سياسي قوله ان
اسرائيل تمسكت بالابقاء على بؤر استيطانيه
عشوائيه واخرى جديده سبق ان اقرتها
الحكومه
من حيث الشكل يعتبر اجتماع العقبه الارفع
مستوى لناحيه الفاعليه بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي منذ سنوات وصفته
صحيفه بانه من اجتماعات التنسيق الامنيه
النادره حضره دبلوماسيون ممثلون عن
الولايات المتحده والاردن ومصر
ومن حيث المضمون نقلت الصحيفه ان ترتيب
الاجتماعي اتى بعد قبول اسرائيل المشاركه
بهدف تهدئه التوترات في المنطقه قبيل شهر
رمضان المبارك ابرز المشاركين في الوفد
الاسرائيلي هم قاده امنيون رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي صح هانكبي رئيس جهاز الامن
الداخلي
والمنسق العسكري مع الفلسطينيين
اما عن الجانب الفلسطيني فقالت جورنال ان
اربعه مستشارين للرئيس محمود عباس شاركوا
في الاجتماع عرف منهم امين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير حسين الشيخ
ورئيس جهاز المخابرات ماجد فرج
الاجتماع الذي عقد بعيدا عن الاعلام خلص
الى تاكيد الجانبين على التزامهما بجميع
الاتفاقات السابقه والعمل على تحقيق
السلام العادل والدائم وخفض التصعيد ومنع
المزيد من العنف والاستعداد لوقف
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب لمده ثلاثه الى
سته اشهر
وتضمن البيان الختامي للاجتماعي ايضا
التزام اسرائيل بوقف اقامه اي وحدات
استيطانيه جديده لمده اربعه اشهر ووقف
اقرار اي بؤر استيطانيه جديده لمده سته
اشهر
كما اتفقت الاطراف المشاركه في اجتماع
العقبه على الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي
القائم في الاماكن المقدسه وشددوا على
الوصايه الهاشميه على المقدسات في القدس
المحتله اضافه الى العوده للاجتماع مجددا
في شرم الشيخ في شهر مارس اذار المقبل
ونقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن مسؤول
سياسيين قوله انه تم الاتفاق ايضا على
تشكيل لجنه امنيه مشتركه لبحث التنسيق
الامني بين السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
وجاهزيه الجانب الفلسطيني لتحمل مسؤوليه
محاربه ما يسمى الارهاب وتشكيل لجنه مدنيه
للدفع بخطوات اقتصاديه لبناء الثقه واضاف
المسؤول بحسب ما نقل عنه ان الوفد
الاسرائيلي اكد انه لن يكون هناك اي تغيير
بشان اطفاء شرعيه على تسع بؤر استيطانيه
عشوائيه وبناء تسعه الاف وخمسمائه
استيطانيه جديده
[موسيقى]
من جهه اخرى رحب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سالفن باجتماع العقبه
واعتبره نقطه انطلاق مضيفا انه يتعين
القيام بعمل جاد خلال الاسابيع المقبله
اناقش الاجتماع وتطورات على الارض مع
ضيوفنا من رام الله حسين حمايل المتحدث
باسم حركه فتح عبر الهاتف من غزه السيد
حسام الدجاني الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
واشنطن جول روبن مساعد نائب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق سيد حمايل ما موقفكم من
التصريحات الاخيره لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو حول الاستيطان
وتشريع البؤره الاستيطانيه الذي خرج بعيده
اعلان اجتماع العقبه
هذه اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء
الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام يعني
اضطررنا ان نشارك من خلال الهاتف بسبب ترد
الاوضاع واعتداءات المستوطنين في المناطق
قريبه من جنوب نابلس وكذلك على مداخل
المدن الفلسطينيه وعلى الشوارع بين المدن
اخي الكريم اولا ما حصل من اجتماع في
العقبه ومن حق القياده الفلسطينيه ان تذهب
بالحراكه الدبلوماسي من اجل المحاوله في
حمايه شعبنا ولكن الموضوع اليوم يحتم على
الاداره الامريكيه وما صدر من تصريحات
نتنياهو وكذلك ما يحصل الان من الاعتداءات
للمستوطنين في بلده حواره بحمايه من الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو يحتم ويبكي
المسؤولي المسؤوليه على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكذلك على المجتمع الدولي
بضروره ان يكون هناك قرارات حقيقيه ترتقي
الى مستوى نجم دوله الاحتلال باجرام
اولا هل التزمت اسرائيل في مع العقبه هل
التزمت بتعليق الاستيطان
يا سيدي الموضوع التزام اسرائيل
في اجتمع الدولي ليلزم اسرائيل ان تتكلم
عن اليوم تتكلم عن اسرائيل بانها دوله
المستوطنين تغولوا فيها بشكل بشكل
كبير جدا اليوم بحاجه اعيد واكرر ما
اسلفته لك من يكرر الالتزام من عدم
الالتزام اذا كان هناك اراده دوليه حقيقيه
لنجم الاجرام والعدوان الاسرائيلي
محققه عندما تقول بان هذا الاجتماع يعطي
غطاء للاحتلال للاستمرار في بطشه على
الفلسطينيين
لا لا لا هذا اولا اسرائيل في موضوع البسط
ضد الفلسطينيين اول امس كانت عشر شهداء 11
شهيد في ناقص وقبل تسع شهداء في جنين
اسرائيل مستمره في اجرامها وقتلها ونحن
عندما نذهب الى اي اجتماع تحاول القياده
الفلسطينيه من خلال لقاءات الدبلوماسيه ان
تحمي شعبها وان تخفف من اجرام دوله
الاحتلال ولكن اخي الكريم انا بحكي لك نحن
نعمل على تنصعد الصعيد
الدبلومات لنذهب الى كل مكان في هذه
الدنيا من اجل المحاوله التخفيف عن شعبنا
ونجم الاحتلال يعني كل محاولات الى لانه
ما زالت الاراده الدوليه لا ترتقي الى
المستوى المطلوب في لجم هذا الاحتلال
والامر الثاني الحراك اللي القانوني
والدولي والمؤسسات الدوليه وسنستمر ايضا
في هذا الحراك والامر الثالث المقاومه
الشعبيه اليوم مطلوب منا ايضا فلسطينيه في
هذا الوقت الذي نعيش ان يبقى ملف المقاومه
الشعبيه مفعله وان يبقى هذا الملف ايضا
اذا سمحت لي مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
يقول بان هذا الاجتماع نقطه ايجابيه ويجب
استكمال الخطوات لخفض التصعيد هل تلقت
السلطه الفلسطينيه ضمانات من الجانب
الامريكي
الجانب الامريكي عندما جاء الرئيس البايد
الرئيس بايدن صرح كثير من التصريحات التي
لها علاقه في المطالب السياسيه التي
طلبتها القياده الفلسطينيه اليوم في هذا
الاجتماع نحن طلبنا في عشر نقاط من من
المجتمعين
يعني تلقى دائما مستمرا شقان الاردنيين
والمصريين الذين يحاولوا يحاولوا ايضا
معنا من اجل التخفيف على الشعب الفلسطيني
يعني عمليا اخي الكريم اليوم لما نتكلم عن
هذا الاجتماع عن اجتماع العقبه وغيره من
الاجتماعات التي تحصل على مستوى العالم هي
محاولات بالنسبه لنا كفلسطينيين وكذلك
القياده الفلسطينيه لن نستطيع ان نثق بهذا
الاحتلال اذا لم يكن هناك تنفيذا حقيقيا
على الارض ودوله الاحتلال بتجربتنا
الطويله معها
المشاركه الشارع الفلسطيني يسال في ظل هذا
التصعيد وعدم قدره
للولايات المتحده ولا المجتمع الدولي على
لجم حكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه المتطرفه ما
الجدوى من المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع اخي
الكريم هو احنا يعني في هذا العالم نجد
احدا يستطيع ان يلزم الاحتلال
ونقف اليوم اخي طارق الاعتداء علينا من
قبل هذا الاحتلال وموضوع خفض
ياتي من دوله الاحتلال ضمن المراه ومشهد
العالم اجمع العرب والمسلمين يروا هذا
الاعتداء ودول العالم ترى هذا الاعتداء
وكذلك من من يصدر التصريحات والاشاعات
ويصرخ ويصدر المواقف البراقه من اجل الشعب
الفلسطيني لم نرى احدا منهم حرك ساكنا مع
الشعب الفلسطيني
بماذا التزمت السلطه الفلسطينيه بهذا
الاجتماع باقتضاب لو سمحت
السلطه الفلسطينيه لديها مجموعه من
الثوابت في هذا الاجتماع وغير هذا
الاجتماع عندما جاءت ترامب اخي الكريم
كانت هناك ضغوطات هو تهديدات ووعيد وكثير
من من
الامور التي دفعها الشعب الفلسطيني بسبب
تبقي على موقفها في حين صفقه القرن وكانت
ترامب يريد انهاء القياده
اخي الكريم
الامني مع القوات الاسرائيليه عاد من
بوابه اللجان الامنيه التي ستشكل
ات كثيره غير التنسيق الامنيين بيحاولوا
يركزوا عليه كثير من الاتفاقيات لها علاقه
بالشعب الفلسطيني اخي الكريم انت لا يجوز
ما بتعرف كيف احنا بنعيش في فلسطين نحن
نعيش في فلسطين ضمن حدود مطبقه ومغلقه اذا
في كثير من القضايا اليوميه والحياتيه
للشعب الفلسطيني يجب ان يكون هناك علاقه
فيها مع هذا المحتل من اجل ان تسير الحياه
اليوميه للفلسطينيين ولكن البعض عندما
ياتي ليصرح تصريحات انا بحكي لك بديل
الهدوء هو حاله من التصعيد التي تقوم بها
دوله الاحتلال ولكن نحن في حركه فتح نؤكد
على ما يلي انه بالنسبه
ما زلنا على موقفنا وسنبقى على موقفنا
الرافض بهذا الاحتفاء الاحتلال والرفض بكل
مكونات هذا الاحتلال
بالنسبه لنا اخي الكريم
ونحن كحركه فتح نقول دائما بان ثوابتنا
خطوط حمر نعم اليوم قد يكون مزال القوه في
العالم لا يخدم القضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن
سنبقى في صبرنا وصمودنا ومقاومتهم شكرا
سيد حسين ان يرحل عن هذه الارض باذن الله
حسين حمايل المتحدث باسم حركه فتح كنت
معنا عبر الهاتف شكرا لك اعود الى ضيفينا
جو الروبن وحسام الدجاني سيد جو روبن ما
قدرت واشنطن على استكمال الخطوات التي
اقرها اجتماع العقبه في ظل التصعيد
المستمر على الارض والتصريحات التي خرجت
من قيادات اسرائيليه حول ما يتعلق
بالاستيطان وتشريعات البؤر الاستيطانيه
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه يسعدني ان اكون
هنا معكم ومع الزملاء الكرام نحن نتحدث عن
اختبار كبير من دون ان شك لاداره بايدن ما
حصل في العقبه هو مهم للغايه لان الاردن
ومصر كان هناك بالاضافه الى الاسرائيليين
وفلسطينيين هذا الاجتماع هو الاول من نوعه
منذ سنوات وبالتالي رساله قويه هناك بعض
الالتزامات التي عبرت عنها اسرائيل على
سبيل المثال الا تتحدث عن بناء وحدات
استطاانيه جديده او بئر استيطانيه بفتره
اربعه الى سته اشهر بالاضافه الى اعاده
الاجتماع في مارس في شرم الشيخ في مصر
وايضا اجراء حوار مباشر بين السلطه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل وهذه اجراءات ملموسه
بالنسبه الى الحكومه الامريكيه الولايات
المتحده سوف تراقب
ما يحصل لكي تتاكد من ان هذه الالتزامات
التي تم التعبير عنها تطبق الاردن ومصر
وضع الكثير على المحاكم كذلك من خلال
استضافه هذا اللقاء من قبل الاردن وفي شهر
اذار مارس مصر سوف تستضيف الاجتماع الاخر
نامل انها نقطه الانطلاق لعمليه دبلوماسيه
للابتعاد عن العنف الذي نشاهده الان واود
ان اذكر ذلك منسوب العنف مرتفع للغايه من
دون ادنى شك عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين يقتلون وبالتالي هذا
الاجتماع هو محاوله لوقفه هذا العنف
والمضي قدما في مسار مختلف لحل المشكلات
ولكن لا اقول انها عمليه سهله سيد حسام
قبل قليل السيد حسين حمايا المتحدث باسم
حركه فتح قال بان البديل عن الهدوء هو
التصعيد ما اسباب مصارعه فصائل فلسطينيه
الى
رفض مشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا
الاجتماع في العقبه الذي تكون تقول عنه
الولايات المتحده بانه نقطه ايجابيه يمكن
البناء عليها
مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك ولكافه المشاهدين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تنطلق ومعها اغلب
مكونات شعبنا الفلسطيني وجزء كبير من
ابناء حركه فتح ومن القياده الوسطى في
حركه فتح تؤمن بان ما يجري من تصعيد هو
نتاس سلوك الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولربما لو
فكرت الولايات المتحده وتاملت بطبيعه
الصراع وطبيعه ان اسرائيل انقلبت على
الاتفاق الاكبر وهو اتفاق اوسلو الذي رعاه
العالم اجمع وعلى راسه الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي لعلموا ان هذه
الاتفاقيات لا جدوى منها ولو تاملت قليلا
في طبيعه هذا الاتفاق لوجدت انه اتفاق
امني بامتياز حتى وان جاء على ذكر قضايا
السياسيه على سبيل المثال عندما يبدا
الاتفاق بدباجه الالتزام بالاتفاقيات
السياسيه كنت اريد ان استمع من اخي حسين
او من غيره كيف من الممكن ان يفسر
الالتزام بالاتفاقيات السياسيه في ظل مثلا
على سبيل المثال مشاريع الاستيطان اي 1
الذي فصل الق كليا عن الضفه الغربيه وصادر
اكثر من تقريبا
12,443 دونم من خلال ربط شرق القدس في
غربها كيف من الممكن ان نتعاطى مع ذلك
كفلسطينيين عندما نتامل ان هذا الحراك
وحاله الغليان هو نتيجه البرنامج الموقع
بين حكومه نتتنياهو وابن غفير كيف من
الممكن ان نتوقع ان اسرائيل ستلتزم بهذا
الاتفاق نعلم جميعا ان اسرائيل انتقلت من
اداره الصراع الى حسم الصراع وحسم الصراع
فقط نتنياهو ما يريد من هذا الاتفاق هو ان
يمرر شهر رمضان بهدوء وبعد شهر رمضان
سيعيد الى شرعنه البوابه الاسطانيه التي
حتى لم ينتظر
عندما قال قبل قليل تبعنا وزير الخارجيه
الاردني قال اجتماع العقبه تضمن التزامات
هامه ستؤدي ان طبقت الى خفض التصعيد
وانخراط سياسي اشمل هل ترى انه هناك
امكانيه لتطبيق ما تم الاتفاق عليه في
العقبه
اذا لم تطبق في زمن حكومات حزب العمل او
كديمه فهل ستطبق في زمن الحكومه الفاشيه
بالتاكيد هذا يهدد مستقبل نتنياهو لو كان
هناك اي التزام سياسي في تقديري ان
نتنياهو يناور ويكسب مزيد من الوقت ويحاول
ان يقضي كل الجبهات ويحاول ان يسير على
الحبال هو عينه على قطار التطبيع ان يمضي
قدما وعينه على ان يمضي شهر رمضان وعينه
ان يعيد السلطه لان تكون اداه للاسف
الشديد من خلال عمليه التنسيق الامني
وبذلك المسار السياسي لا يمكن ان يكون
حاضرا لو طبقت اسرائيل قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه والزمتها الاداره الامريكيه في
تطبيق قرار
الاستيطان لربما لوجدنا مبررات لهذا
الاتفاق ولكن في تقدير ان اسرائيل تحاول
والاداره الامريكيه للاسف تحاول ان تنقذ
نتنياهو من اي تصعيد في شهر رمضان في ظل
حاله الغليان التي لم تعد لفصيل سياسي
معين بالمناسبه لمن لا يعلم اغلب حاله في
الضفه الغربيه من ابناء حركه فتح طيب سيد
جويل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
تتحدث عن حل الدولتين كيف نفهم انخراطها
في هذا الاجتماع ما يتعلق بجوانب امنيه
ربما ضيقه ومحدوده وعلى فتره زمنيه ايضا
محدوده نتحدث عن اشهر اقصاها سته ماذا
نفهم من هذا الانخراط الامريكي في هذا
الجانب
هذا صحيح
حل الدولتين هو الهدف وهو سياسه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه منذ سنوات في ايام
اداره ترامب شاهدنا ابتعادا عن هذا الهدف
ولكن هذا الهدف عاد مع اداره بايدن امل ان
الظروف التي نحن بحاجه اليها للتوصل الى
حل الدبلوماسي سوف تستحدث من خلال بيئه
يعمرها سلام بشكل اكبر انا افهم ما قاله
الضيف ان يمر شهر رمضان بشكل هادئ هذا ما
يريده نتنياهو لكن اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى
شهر رمضان هذا واشهر هادئه يكون فيها خفض
للتصعيد وعمليات القتل وفتح حوار بين
السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بانخراط من
قبل مصر والاردن بدعم من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا هو اله يجب ان اقول كذلك ان
نتنياهو يتعرض الى ضغوط داخليه كبيره ويجب
ان اخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار من الواضح ان
لديه حكومه يمنيه في السلطه اليوم وهو
يتعرض الى ضغوط من قبل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ومن السياسيين الاسرائيليين في شان مواقف
داخليه اسرائيليه
هذا يؤدي الى ضغوط لا نعرف ما هي النتيجه
لا نعرف ما هي حسابات نتنياهو نعم هناك
حكومات وقعت في السابق
على اتفاقيات مع دول عربيه بما في ذلك
اتفاقيه بين مصر واسرائيل وبالتالي هذه
المرحله هي اساسيه للوصول الى حوار وهذا
هو الموقف الامريكي في الامد القريب شكرا
لكما جول روبن في واشنطن وحسام الدجني في
غزه
قبل ثلاثه عقود خرج اتفاق اسلوب ترتيبات
حددت خريطه وصلاحيات السلطه الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه الى ان
الاحتلال ضل طيله هذه المده يوسع من دائره
الاستيطان والقواعد العسكريه والانتشار
والاستيلاء على الاراضي متجاهلا وجود
السلطه الفلسطينيه مما جعل الاتفاق في مهب
الريح
تبلغ مساحه الضفه الغربيه نحو
5760 كيلومترا مربعا منحه اتفاق اسطو
السلطه الفلسطينيه صلاحيه للعمل في
المناطق الف وباء مع السيطره الاسرائيليه
كامله على المنطقه المصنفه جيم نحو 21% من
اجمالي مساحه الضفه يقع ضمن المنطقه الف
وتخضع امليا واداريا بشكل كامل للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ومع اندلاع الانتفاضه الثانيه
عام 2000 عادت اسرائيل احتلالها بشكل كامل
ولم تنسحب منها بشكل كلي المنطقه ب وتقطع
اداريا للسلطه الفلسطينيه وامنيه لاسرائيل
وتقدر مساحتها بنحو 18% من مساحه الضفه
وهي غالبا مناطق ماهوله في القرى والضواحي
وبينما يعيش نحو 90% من الفلسطينيين في
المناطق المصنفه الف وباء يعيش عشره في
المئه في المناطق المصنفه جيم وهي اكبر
مساحه وتخضع امنيا ومدنيا لاسرائيل دون
السماح للسلطه
بممارسه دورها في هذه المناطق تتحكم
اسرائيل كليا بمعظم اراضي الضفه الغربيه
وتسيطر عسكريا عليها وتتوسع استيطانيا
بينما تسيطر السلطه الفلسطينيه جزئيا على
مراكز المدن دون سياده امنيه تامه بحلول
عام 2021 بلغ مجموع المساحات المصادره
لصالح المستوطنات نحو 40% من مساحه الضفه
الغربيه وبلغ عدد البؤر الاستيطانيه اكثر
من 300 بؤره كما اسهمت شبكه الطرق
الالتفافيه التي اقمتها اسرائيل بطوله 980
كم في اختراق المناطق الفلسطينيه وتقطيع
اوصال التجمعات الريفيه في الضفه الغربيه
ثارت تساؤلات عن جدول اتفاق اوسلو مع
الاقتحامات المتكرره للقوات الاسرائيليه
لمناطق تتبع السلطه الفلسطينيه في الشمال
وطرا في عام 2022 ومطلع هذا العام مستجد
النوعي في المعادله بظهور مجموعات
فلسطينيه مسلحه بمسميات مختلفه في منطقتين
نابلس وجنين وشن هجمات منفرده على
مستوطنين
وافض لما فرضته اسرائيل من وقائع بعد
تقسيم الضفه بدا حل دولتين بلا معنى
فالمناطق المصنفه الف وباء باتت بدورها
مجزاه ومقسمه بطرق وقواعد عسكريه
اسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
انسحاب من معاهده ستارت التي تهدف للحد من
الاسلحه النوويه ثم حديث عن ضروره اخذ
القدرات النوويه للدول الاوروبيه الرائده
في حلف شمال الاطلسي بعين الاعتبار مواقف
متتاليه تصب في اتجاه واحد وهو تعالي نبره
الحديث عن احتمالات مواجهه نوويه بين
روسيا والنيتو لا من جانب المراقبين وانما
على لسان الرئيس الروسي الذي يتهم الدول
الاوروبيه بمحاوله الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه
ببلاده
تلويح بمواجهه ام استعداد للاسواء تصريحات
الرئيس الروسي بشان القدرات النوويه لدول
الناتو خصوصا بريطانيا وفرنسا تعيد الى
الواجهه احتمالات توسع المواجهه بين روسيا
ودول الحلف فالرئيس فلاديمير بوتين اتهم
الدول الرائده في الحلف برغبتها في الحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا وشدد على ضروره
اخذ قدراته النوويه بعين الاعتبار مشددا
على ان اخراج الحلف من معاهده ستارت كان
في سياق انفراج العلاقات ما يعني تغيرا في
مقاربه روسيا للنيتو الذي تقول انه لم يعد
منظمه سياسيه بل كتله عسكريه
جغرافيا حدود روسيا مع دول النيتو لا
تتجاوز سته في المئه من مجمل حدود روسيا
الا ان قبول عضويه السويد وفنلندا سيزيد
من ذلك وهو مصدر قلق بالغ وحساسيه شديده
بالنسبه لروسيا التي لها حدود مع اربع
عشره دوله خمس منها عضو في الحلف ولا يخفي
المسؤولون الروس توجزهم من تمدد الحلف
واقترابه اكثر من حدود بلادهم فحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا بنظر مؤيديها وقائيه لمنع
تمدد النيتو واقترابه اكثر وقبلها كانت
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في جورجيا سنه
2008 يزيد من حده هذه الهواجس ما اعلن عن
عدم ممانعه السويد وفنلندا تثبيت اسلحه
نوويه للنيتو على اراضيهما بعد تاكيد
انضمامهما وهو ما يعني تضييق الهامش
الزمني المتاح للروس للاستعداد ورغم ان
لدى روسيا كما تقول اكثر مما تملكه دول
النيتو مجتمعه في الرؤوس النوويه المحموله
على الصواريخ العابره للقارات الا ان
الحلف يتفوق على روسيا في الرؤوس النوويه
التي يمكن تحميلها على غواصات او التي
يمكن اطلاقها من الطائرات المقاتله
تشتد نبره التصريحات بين روسيا والغرب
ومعها يزداد تصعيد السياسات والمواقف
اخرها الانسحاب من معاهده ستارت وتحت يد
كل من الفريقين اسلحه دمار شامل
السفير الامريكي السابق لدى الناتو ومن
موسكو ديمتري الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سيد
فولكر كيف فهمتم رساله الرئيس الاوكراني
الروسي عفوا بحديثه عن القدرات النوويه
لدول حلف شمال الاطلسي
في الحقيقه اعتقد في البدايه ان
يحاول ان يحذر البلدان الاخرى بان روسيا
لديها اسلحه نوويه ويمكنها ان تستخدم هذه
الاسلحه من خلال تسطيط الضوء على قدرات
النوويه وايضا يحاول ان يلقي اللوم على
الطرف الاخر بالنسبه الى اتفاقيه او
معاهده ستارت وهذا ما يود ان يقوم به يود
ان يلقي اللوم على الطرف الاخر تعالي نبره
الحديث عن السلاح النووي هل ممكن ان يؤدي
بالضروره الى استخدامه فعليا على الارض
امل ان لا يؤدي الى ذلك حيث ان ذلك فظيع
بالنسبه الى الانسانيه ان نرى ان الاسلحه
النوويه تستخدم في الحرب وهذا غير منطقي
ببساطه اذا ما حاولت روسيا ان تسيطر على
الاراضي في اوكرانيا من خلال استعمال
الاسلحه النوويه تدمر الاراضي وتصبح غير
ماهوله اذا ما استخدمت الاسلحه النوويه
وبالتالي هذا غير منطقي وايضا سوف يؤدي
ذلك الى رد فعل من العالم الغربي ومن كل
انحاء العالم وهذا ما لا تريده روسيا هذا
العالم الغربي والولايات المتحده تحديدا
كيف تتعامل مع هذا التلويح من فتره الى
اخرى من قبل روسيا بالسلاح نووي اما قدره
او استخداما عند الضروره
لحسن الحظ هنا
الهدوء يعم في اوساط الجميع هناك عمليه
حسابيه تقول ان بوتين ليس في مصلحته ان
يستخدم الاسلحه النوويه ومن احد في الغرب
ولا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يود ان
يصعد من خلال اللجوء الى خطاب النووي نحن
لا نرى ان الحاجه هي لاستخدام الاسلحه
النوويه وبالتالي هناك هدوء في الجانب
الغربي ما مبعث هذا الاطمئنان سيد فولكر
الهدوء
ببساطه مرده الى ان هذا الامر برايي
واشنطن غير منطقي ليس من مصلحه روسيا ان
تستخدم الاسلحه النوويه ولذلك ليست مبعث
قلق واذا ما استخدمت ضدنا هناك ردع
استراتيجي لا يزال قائما وحتى الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه التي قد تستعمل في
اوكرانيا لن تؤدي الى تحقيق اهدافي روسيا
في الميدان حيث ان روسيا تكون بالفعل نفسه
دمرت الاراضي التي تود ان تحصل عليها وهذا
يؤثر سلبا على القوات الروسيه في الميدان
طبعا لسوء الحظ الرئيس بوتين هو من باشر
بهذه التصريحات ولكن ما من احد يود ان
يصعد باللجوء الى الاسلحه النوويه شكرا لك
السفير كيرت فولكر السفير الامريكي السابق
لدى نيتو سيد
عواقب المحتمله لما قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بانها محاوله من الدول
الاوروبيه لالحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا
الواضح ان الغرب يود ان يلحق هزيمه
استراتيجيه بروسيا في اوكرانيا وهذا ما
عبر عنه الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
ستوتنبر بالاضافه الى رئيس مجلس الوزراء
بورس جونسون
وبالاضافه الى قاده اخرين الرئيس بوتين لم
يهدد باستخدام روسيا الاسلحه النوويه وهو
ذكر فقط حقيقه ان روسيا لديها ترسان نوويه
والغرب كذلك ولذلك اعتقد انه يطلب من
الغرب ان يتصرف بشكل مسؤول ولكننا استمعنا
الى السفير فولكر والذي كان سفير الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لدى اوكرانيا قبل الحرب
في العام 2022 وفي 2020 و2019 كان السيد
فولكر في اوكرانيا
كانت تقول روسيا لن تهاجم ولن تدخل في هذه
الحرب ولكن هذه النقطه كانت خطا حيث ان
السيد والغرب لم انا باستطاعتي بوتين ان
يواجه النيت في محاولته التوسعيه وهناك
قوات اضافيه في اوكرانيا وحتى كان هناك
حديث عن مواقع وقواعد للنيتو في اوكرانيا
في الحقيقه كان هناك قواعد للولايات
المتحده والبريطانيا في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
عندما اجتاحت روسيا اوكرانيا في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير تفاجا ان من مثل السيد
فولكر وقالوا نفس الشيء الذي يقولونه عن
مقاله السيد فولكر وعنه شخصيا سيد ديمتري
قلت الرئيس بوتين لم يهدد باستخدام النووي
نريد ان نعرف تقييمك لمقاله وقال حرفيا
بانه يجب ان ناخذ القدرات النوويه لدول
حلف شمال الاطلسيه الناتو بعين الاعتبار
ما المقصود اذا هدى اذا لم يكن التلوح
باستخدام السلاح النووي ما المقصود هنا
اذا بالتقييم الروسي
يحاول ان يجذب انتباه القاده في الغرب الى
حقيقه ان الوضع يصبح اكثر خطوره هم يرسلون
اسلحه متقدمه جديده الى ميدان المعركه لكي
يقتلوا اكبر عدد ممكن من الجنود الروس كما
يقولون الرئيس زيلينسكي يتحدث عن احتمال
اجتياح شبه جزيره القرم من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه هذه التصرفات سوف تؤدي الى رد
فعل روسي وبوتين يحاول ان يهدئ من هذه
التصريحات والتصرفات يقول لدينا اسلحه
نوويه ولديكم اسلحه نوويه اذا ما اتخذتم
قرارات مسؤوله واذا ما لم تتبع رغبه
باستعاده القرم هذا جيد ولكن اذا ما قمتم
بالعكس هذا يؤدي الى كارثه وبالتالي بوتين
يحذر وهذا ما يريده من خلال هذه التصريحه
شكرا
[موسيقى]
بدنيا ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قوتها صدت واحدا وسبعين هجوم روسيا معظمها
على محاور القتال في اقليم دومباس شرقيه
اوكرانيا خلال الساعات الاخيره واضافت
انها احبطت العديد من المحاولات الروسيه
للتقدم نحو مواقع قواتها في مدينه
وقالت مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان اعنف
المعارك تدور في المحور الشمالي لمدينه
بخموت كما وصفت الوضع على الضفه الشرقيه
لنهر بخموت بالحرج
المثال لخار كيف
قال الرئيس الاوكراني خلال استقباله وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
في كييف قال ان هذه الزياره وهي الاولى من
نوعها منذ اقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه بين
البلدين ستوفر زخما جديدا بين البلدين
وشكر زيلينسكي وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على
دعم بلاده للسلام ولسياده وسلامه اوكرانيا
في المقابل قالت الخارجيه السعوديه على
موقعها الالكتروني ان الوزير جدد حرص
المملكه ودعمها لكافه الجهود الدوليه
الراميه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
سياسيا ومواصله الجهود للاسلام للاسهام في
تخفيف الاثار الانسانيه الناجمه عنها
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان المملكه حريصه على الوصول الى
حل سلمي للحرب في اوكرانيا وهي تعمل مع
جميع الاطراف للتوصل الى تسويه وضاف خلال
مؤتمر صحفيين مع نظيره الاوكراني في كييف
ان السعوديه تقدمت مساعده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
410 ملايين دولار
توجيه القياده بتقديم حزبتين من المساعدات
الانسانيه الاوكرانيه بمبلغ اجمالي 410
مليون دولار وقد وقعنا اليوم على اتفاقتين
تؤسس لتسليم هذه
الاعانات والمملكه
حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب ونحن في موقع السعوديه لان لدينا
قاصر قناع راسخه ان اي نهايه للحرب يجب ان
يكون بالحوار ويجون على طاوله في اطار
مبادئ القانون الدولي والميثاق الامم
المتحده واحترام سياده الدول ولهذا سوف
نستمر في العمل مع جميع الاطراف للبحث عن
فرص الوصول الى هكذا تسويه
[موسيقى]
ارتفع عدد قتلى حادث ارتطام قارب خشبي
بالصخور قبله سواحل منطقه كالابريا
الايطاليه الى نحو 60 شخصا من طالبي
اللجوء وكان على متن القارب حوالي 200 شخص
من افغانستان وباكستان وايران يذكر ان
الحكومه الايطاليه اليمنيه تبنت قبل فتره
قوانين جديده صارمه بشان عمليات الانقاذ
ومنع وصول طالبيه اللجوء الى سواحلها
لوقف تدفق المهاجرين
قالت ان الحكومه ملتزمه بمنع المغادرين
ومعهم هذا النوع من الماسي سنواصل القيام
بذلك يتطلب الامر قبل كل شيء تعاونا اكبر
من دول المغادره والمنشا استنادا لوزاره
الداخليه الايطاليه وصل الى البلاد اكثر
من 14 الف مهاجر منذ بدايه العام الجاري
مقارنه بخمسه الاف وثلاث مئه خلال نفس
الفتره من العام الماضي الحقيقه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يدخر جهدا ومالا لمنع
وصول المهاجرين الى القاره العجوز
للمفارقه في اجتماع الجمعه الماضيه باثينا
دعت خمسه عشره دوله في الاتحاد الى تعزيز
الحدود الخارجيه
لمواجهه تدفق المهاجرين وابرام اتفاقات مع
دوله ثالثه لاستقبالهم في نفس الاجتماع
قيل ان حدود اوروبا مفتوحه للمهاجرين
الاوكرانيين كما طالبت عده دول بما في
واليونان من الاتحاد تمويل اقامه حواجز
على الحدود الخارجيه لصد طالبي اللجوء
نقطه وصول كثير منهم هي عرض البحر الابيض
المتوسط مقبره بلا شواهد لمن ارادوا ان
يشهدوا حياه افضل وفي النهايه ماتوا غرقا
في ايطاليا السيده فاليريا فارجيون استاذه
الدراسات الاوروبيه في جامعه فلورنسا
سيلفاليا هل تتحمل ايطاليا ايضا مسؤوليه
غرق العشرات
لسوء الحظ نعم اود في البدايه واسمح لي ان
اعبر عن تعزيه الحاره وعن اسف الشديد هذه
ماساه حصلت لسوء الحظ انا اعرف ان للحكومه
الايطاليه مسؤوليه وليست مباشره ولكن هناك
مسؤوليه هذا القانون الذي قر على مستوى
البرلمان مؤخرا هذا القانون يصعب بشكل
كبير عمليات الانقاذ من قبل قوارب
المنظمات غير الحكوميه ما الذي اعنيه بذلك
اذا هذا التشريع الجديد ينص على ان قارب
الانقاذ متى
يقوم
بانقاذ الناس يتعين عليه ان يتجه باتجاه
الميناء المحدد من قبل الحكومه والامر
الجنوني هو ان الميناء يبتعد اكثر من الف
ميل عن المنطقه التي جرت فيها عمليه
الانقاذ ما الذي يعنيه ذلك يعني ذلك ان
المراكب مراكب التابعه للمنظمات غير
الحكوميه وهي خمسه الان على سبيل المثال
تبقى بعيده عن المنطقه التي هي بمس الحاجه
لان تكون فيها هناك غرامه فرضت على احد
القوارب لان هذا القارب انقذ مجموعه من
الناس وبعد ذلك تلقى اتصالا ولكنه لم يكن
يتعين عليه وفقا للتشريع الجديد
بان يقوم بانقاذ مجموعه ثانيه ومجموعه
ثالثه كان يتعين على القارب ان يتجه نحو
الميناء المحدد من قبل الحكومه لذلك
ان هذا القانون هو ضد القانون الدولي هو
خرق بالحديث عن هذا القانون سيده فاليريا
طالما انه خارق للقانون الدولي نعلم بان
هناك تشريعات للاتحاد الاوروبي هل تستطيع
هذه التشريحات او التشريعات عفوا ان تنقض
هذا القانون الذي وصفتيه بانه سيء والذي
اقر في البرلمان الايطالي
ليس الى هذه الدرجه لا تتمكن من القيام
بذلك ولكن امل ان هذا جرس الانذار ان يكون
قد دق
للمفوضيه الاوروبيه
للمضي قدما في ميثاق الهجره
واللجوء وتم وقف العمل لمده سنتين ونصف
بهذا الموضوع وحتى قبل ذلك عمليا لم يكن
هناك خطوات عمليه او قدرات للتوصلي الى
اتفاق مشترك حول كيفيه تحسين القانون
الاوروبي المرتبط بسياسات الهجره الان
المسؤوليه ملقاه على الدول الاعضاء وهي
تقرر من يدخل ومن لا يدخل الوضع الحالي
ياتي بتشريعات من هذا النوع هناك معايير
مرتبطه
باستقبال المهاجرين والاجراءات التي تتم
على مستوى الدول الاوروبيه لطالبي اللجوء
ولكن القانون لو سمحت لي سؤال اخير واريد
اجابه باقتضاب اموال كثيره صرفت لاسيما
الاتحاد الاوروبي لوقف هذه الهجره
وخاصه لايواء هؤلاء اللاجئين فيما تعرف
بدول المغادره
ما الذي حققه هذا المشروع حتى الان
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان هذه السياسه لم تنظر
الى المدى البعيد هي تهدف الى ابعاد
الحدود كي تتاكد من ان
المهاجرين لن يصلوا الى
القاره الاوروبيه لانه على القاره او في
القاره الاوروبيه القانون الاوروبي هو
الذي ينطبق وبالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي
يحاول ان يبعد شكرا هذا ما حاول القيام به
مع تركيا والان مع شمال افريقيا شكرا لك
السيده فاليريا فارجيون استاذه الدراسات
الاوروبيه في جامعه فلورنسا في ايطاليا
شكرا لك
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
ابرز مسارات الهجره عبر العالم ونسال
ضيفنا عن سبل التنسيق لمنع مقتل مزيد من
طالب اللجوء في قوارب الموت
اذا مستمرون معكم في الحصاد ونلتقي على
راس الساعه تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه اليكم
تذكيرا بابرز عناوين حصاد الليله
تصعيد في الضفه وتفاهمات في العقبه
الاحتلال يقتل فلسطينيا في نابلس
ومستوطنون يحرقون منازل ويعتدون على
الطواقم الطبيه بعد مقتل مستوطنين في
حواره باطلاق النار الاحتلال يشدد
الاجراءات الامنيه في الضفه الغربيه
وحكومته توسع الاجراءات الانتقاميه
وفي تفاهمات العقبه وبعد التزامات
فلسطينيه اسرائيليه بخفض التصعيد والعنف
وتعليق مؤقت لاجراءات الاحاديه والانشطه
الاستيطانيه الجديده نتنياهو يقول ان
البناء الاستيطاني وتشريع البؤر
الاستيطانيه لن يتوقفاه واشنطن وعمان
والقاهره تتحدث عن خطوات لبناء الثقه
والفصائل تحذر من توفير غطاء لجرائم
الاحتلال
معارك السيطره تحتدم في محيط مدينه مخموت
الاستراتيجيه الشرقيه اوكرانيا كيف تقول
ان الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات من الشركاء
الغربيين غير كافيه وتتوقع مواجهه صعوبات
ميدانيه في الربيع والصيف
وبوتين يقول ان روسيا في مواجهه فعليه مع
الناتو
وان الصراع يقتضي اخذ القدرات النوويه
لدول الحلف بعين الاعتبار
[موسيقى]
المتوسط يبتلع المزيد من الضحايا غداه
اعتماد روما قانونا يقيد عمليات الانقاذ
في البحر ويعرقل وصول الناجين لموانئها
غرقوا نحو 60 من طالبي لجوء بينهم اطفال
بعد تحطم مركبهم قباله سواحل ايطاليا
ودعوات اوروبيه لوضع قواعد جديده ومشتركه
لحل تعقيدات الهجره
ساعه قليله بعد الكشف عن التزامات
فلسطينيه اسرائيليه في اجتماع العقبه
بالتهدئه وخفض التصعيد تتسارع الاحداث في
الضفه الغربيه ويتسع مشهد التوتر فقد قتل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا بالرصاص
الحي الجنوبيا نابلس وتزامن ذلك ما احراق
مستوطنين منازل فلسطينيين ومحال تجاريه في
بلده حواره جنوبيه نابلس كما اعلن الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني اصابه عشرات الفلسطينيين
جراء اعتداء المستوطنين عليهم في المنطقه
وسجل اعتداء على ثلاث سيارات اسعاف ومنع
طواقم صحفيه من تغطيه هذه الاعتداءات
الحرب محله وفي وقت سابق قتل مستوطنان
اسرائيليان في هجوم نفذه فلسطينيون في
بلده حواره جنوبيه نابلس وردا على الهجوم
اقرت لجنه وزاريه اسرائيليه مشروعه قرار
يقضي بفرض عقوبه الاعدام على فلسطينيين
نفذوا عمليات ضد اسرائيليين في المقابل
قالت فصائل فلسطينيه ان عمليه حواره رد
طبيعي على مجازر الاحتلال ونددت بمشاركه
مسؤولين فلسطينيين في اجتماع العقبه
بالاردن الذي يستهدف حسب مصادر فلسطينيه
خفض التصعيد الاسرائيلي ووقف الاجراءات
احاديه الجانب بحق الفلسطينيين
هي عمليه لافته في توقيتها وسياقها اسفرت
عن مقتل مستوطنين على يد مسلح فلسطيني في
الشارع الرئيسي داخل بلده حوار جنوبي يناب
العمليه تلاها سيل من ردود الفعل قوات
الاحتلال اغلقت مداخل المدينه وشرعت في
البحث عن منفذ الهجوم
ومستوطنون اعتدوا على فلسطينيين في بلدات
وقرى مجاوره للمستوطنات في نابلس فيما
طالب مسؤولون سياسيون ورؤساء تجمعات
الاستيطانيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه بسحب
وفضها من خدمه العقبه ردا على الاجتماع
الامن الخطير الفصائل الفلسطينيه التي
دانت عقب اجتماع طارئ لها في غزه مشاركه
مسؤولين فلسطينيين في قمه العقبه
واعتبرتها جريمه وطنيه لما تحمله من خطط
امريكيه تهدف الى وعد المقاومه بركه
العمليه ووصفتها بالنوعيه ورات فيها ردا
طبيعيا على ج الاحتلال لغه مستوطني الحاله
الفلسطينيه تتجه نحو التكاتف والتعاضد في
عمل وطني شعبي مقاوم ستستمر المقاومه على
الارض
سيتم تفعيلها اكثر ردا على كل هذه
المؤامرات التي تجري لاضعاف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ومحاصرتها
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه التي شاركت في اجتماع
العقبه للمره الاولى منذ سنواته مع
مسؤولين اسرائيليين بحضور مصري واردني
ورعايه امريكيه اكدت التزامها بقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه لانهاء الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
والمطالبه بوقف جميع الاجراءات الاحاديه
الجانب من سلطات الاحتلال اما حركه فتح
فشددت على موقفها الثابت من اي تحرك يهدف
الى نجم الاحتلال ووقف عدوانه على
الفلسطينيين اللقاء مع المجتمع الدولي
واللقاء مع في ظل طبعا وجود القياده
الاردنيه
والاشقاء المصريين هو امر مهم في حمايه
الشعب الفلسطيني من هذا الاحتلال وهذا
الامر لا يلغي ايضا الحراك الذي تقوم به
حركه فتحه تقوم به الفصائل الفلسطينيه على
الارض في موضوع المقاومه الشعبيه وفي
موضوع التصدي للاحتلال والمستوطنين
هجوم حواره جاء في وقت تباينت فيه المواقف
بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه بشان قمه العقبه
لكن القاسم المشترك بينها كما تقول هو
نصره المقاومه باشكالها المختلفه لوقف
جرائم الاحتلال ومستوطنيه التي وصفت بانها
الاكثر دمويه منذ بدايه هذا العام سمير
ابو شماله الجزيره رام الله فلسطين
[موسيقى]
اذا في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه اقر البيان
الختامي الاجتماعي امني وسياسي التزام
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي بخفض
التصعيد ومنع العنف اضافه الى الحفاظ على
الوضع التاريخي القائم في الاماكن المقدسه
ونقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول سياسيا قوله
ان اسرائيل تمسكت بالابقاء على بؤر
استيطانيه عشوائيه واخرى جديده سبق ان
اقرتها الحكومه
[موسيقى]
لكن يعتبر اجتماع العقبه الارفع مستوى
لناحيه الفاعليه بين الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي منذ السنوات وصفته صحيفه وولد
بانه من اجتماعات التنسيق الامنيه النادره
حضره دبلوماسيون ممثلون عن الولايات
المتحده والاردن ومصر
ومن حيث المضمون نقلت الصحيفه ان ترتيب
الاجتماعي اتى بعد قبول اسرائيل المشاركه
بهدف تهدئه التوترات في المنطقه قبيل شهر
رمضان المبارك ابرز المشاركين في الوفد
الاسرائيلي هم قاده امنيون رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي صحبي رئيس جهاز الامن
الداخلي
والمنسق العسكري مع الفلسطينيين
اما عن الجانب الفلسطيني فقالت جورنال ان
اربعه مستشارين للرئيس محمود عباس شاركوا
في الاجتماع عرف منهم امين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير حسين الشيخ
ورئيس جهاز المخابرات ماجد فرج
الاجتماع الذي عقد بعيدا عن الاعلام خلص
الى تاكيد الجانبين على التزامهما بجميع
الاتفاقات السابقه والعمل على تحقيق
السلام العادل والدائم وخفض التصعيد ومنع
المزيد من العنف والاستعداد لوقف
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب لمده ثلاثه الى
سته اشهر
وتضمن البيان الختامي للاجتماعي ايضا
التزام اسرائيل بوقف اقامه اي وحدات
استيطانيه جديده لمده اربعه اشهر ووقف
اقرار اي بؤر استيطانيه جديده لمده سته
اشهر
كما اتفقت الاطراف المشاركه في اجتماع
العقبه على الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي
القائم في الاماكن المقدسه وشددوا على
الوصايه الهاشميه على المقدسات في القدس
المحتله اضافه الى العوده للاجتماع مجددا
في شرم الشيخ في شهر مارس اذار المقبل
ونقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن مسؤول
سياسيين قوله انه تم الاتفاق ايضا على
تشكيل لجنه امنيه المشتركه لبحث التنسيق
الامني بين السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
وجاهزيه الجانب الفلسطيني لتحمل مسؤوليه
محاربه ما يسمى الارهاب وتشكيل لجنه مدنيه
للدفع بخطوات اقتصاديه لبناء الثقه واضاف
المسؤول بحسب ما نقل عنه ان الوفد
الاسرائيلي اكد انه لن يكون هناك اي تغيير
بشان اطفاء شرعيه على تسع بؤر استيطانيه
عشوائيه وبناء تسعه الاف
وخمسمائه استيطانيه جديده
[موسيقى]
جهه اخرى رحب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سالفن رحب باجتماع العقبه
واعتبره نقطه انطلاق مضيفا انه يتعين
القيام بعمل جاد خلال الاسابيع المقبله
معنى من تل ابيب مائير جيفن ديفر الباحث
السياسي الاسرائيلي سيد مئر بماذا التزمت
اسرائيل باجتماع العقبه
في البدايه قبل ان ابدا اود ان اتقدم
بالتعازي
لعائله
الفلسطينيين في هجوم حواره بالاضافه الى
عائلات الاسرائيليين الذين
تاثروا بالهجوم الارهابي اليوم اذا
بالنسبه الى
اجتماع العقبه يتوقف الامر عما او لمن
نطرح او على من اطرح السؤال اذا الاردن
تحدث عن التزام الاسرائيلي بعدم توسيع
الاستيطان ولكن الحكومه الاسرائيليه تنكر
اذا الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا ترى ان هناك
اي تغيير على مستوى السياسه الاستيطانيه
امام هذا الواقع الى اين تسير الامور وما
الذي يمكن ان يطبق اذا من اجتماع العقبه
وما خرج به
نحن نتجه باتجاه فظيع
فمن جهه نحن نرى ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هي اكثر حكومه عنصريه في تاريخ اسرائيل
وهي اكثر حكومه مناهضه للسلام
ومناهضه
للفلسطينيين في تاريخ اسرائيل والحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه لا يمكنها ان تستمر
اكرر لا يمكنها ان تستمر اذا ما قررت ان
تجمد العمليه الاستيطانيه سوف تنتهي لذلك
نتنياهو لن يتخذ هذا القرار من ناحيه اخرى
نحن نرى منظمات ارهابيه فلسطينيه تهاجم
المدنيين الاسرائيليين وليس الجنود
الاسرائيليين ما يصب الزيت على النار نحن
نتحدث عن وضع صعب للغايه في العلاقات
الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
قال بان حكومه تتنياهو خطرا على امن
اسرائيل ما الحسابات التي تتحكم
بقرارات نتنياهو فيما يتعلق بالاستيطان
وبخفض التصعيد على الاقل في الفتره
الزمنيه التي وضعت في اجتماع العقبه
نتحدث عن اولويتين بالنسبه الى السيد
نتنياهو الاولويه الاولى بقاء الحكومه
التي شكلها عفوا اذا بقاؤه هو على المستوى
السياسي
ثانيا
الاصلاحات التي يود ان يطبقها من اجل
اضعاف السلطه القضائيه في اسرائيل
لترسيخ
سلطته هذه هي الاولويات لو كان لديه
اهتمام بالسلام او بالامن ما كان ليسمح
للسيدس والسيد
ولذين قلا
تفوها بامور عنصريه اتجاه الفلسطينيين اذا
ما كان ليسمح لهما بان يتمتع بهذه السلطه
من جانب اخر ارى ان الفلسطينيين يتحملون
جزءا من المسؤوليه بالنسبه الى الوضع ولكن
بالنسبه الى نتنياهو بقائه على مستوى
السياسي هو الاهم
ويود ان يضعف الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل
والمنظمات المتطرفه منظمه السيد سماتريتش
وبنبير هم الحلفاء لنتنياهو وهو سعيد
بالعمل معهم كيف تفهمون انخراط الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذا الجانب الجانب
الامني التكتيكي البحث في امور لا تستطيع
حتى الولايات المتحده ان تكون ضامنه في
القرارات حتى التي خرجت من هذا الاجتماع
وهي طبعا تجميد الاستيطان
صحيح صحيح انت على حق مئه في المئه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقول شيء
والحكومه الاسرائيليه تفعل شيئا اخر من
مصلحه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان يتم
تجميد العمليه الاستطانيه ولكن هذا الامر
ليس بمصلحه الحكومه الاسرائيليه حكومه
نتنياهو لان الحكومه سوف تنهار وتنتهي
وتتفكك في حال تم تجميد العمليه
الاستيطانيه لان شركاء نتنياهو وخصوصا
السيد سمو
فير اذا بالنسبه الى حلفائه هذه من الشروط
الاساسيه لكي يستمروا في الحكومه وبالتالي
طبعا يجب ان تتوقف العمليات الارهابيه من
الجانب الفلسطيني ويجب على اسرائيل ان
توقف المتطرف المستوطنين وتوسيع الاستيطان
لكي نصل الى السلام ولكن كلا الطرفين لا
يطبق ذلك الولايات المتحده تحاول ولكن لا
اعتقد انها سوف تنجح مقير جافيد نفر
الباحث السياسي الاسرائيلي في تل ابيب
شكرا لك حول نفس الموضوع ينضم الينا من
رام الله السيد محمد المصري رئيس المركز
الفلسطيني للبحوث والدراسات الاسرائيليه
سيد المصري
ما تقييمكم ودلالات التصريحات الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه التي تلت الاعلان عن اجتماع
العقبه
تحياتي لك وكافه المشاهدين الكرام دعني
اقول بالجانب الاول بانه على القياده
الفلسطينيه ان تذهب في كل مكان من اجل
حمايه شعبها وتفعل ما تستطيع ان كان عمل
السياسي والدبلوماسي والحقوق والاتصالات
سعيد كل المنظمات الدوليه لتفعل شيئا ما
ليحمي الشعر وقدبت المطالب في هذا اللقاء
ولكن على المقلب الثاني هناك تقريبا
بالساعه التاسعه او اقل دقائق فتح اعلنت
النفير العام
وكتائب الاقصى هي التي واجهت المستوطنين
في حواره وكان هناك هروب جماعي وبالتالي
الفعل كل منهما يستطيع ان يفعل في مكانه
بقدر امكانياته ابناء شعبنا الفلسطيني
تصدوا لكمال القطاع المستوطنين المسلحين
والكل يعرف انه في المستوطنين بالضفه
لديهم اكثر من 400 الف قطعه سلاح هذا كذا
يقول الجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي كما يسموه
الجانب الاخر المستوطنين محميين ايضا
بالجيش نفسه لذلك نقول ما حصل في العقبه
تج
تجاوزت الحريق حريق يعني حواره حورك زعتره
برقين وبالتالي ما حصل في الميدان هذه
حكومه فاشيه لا تتصف بالمصداقيه ولا
بالثقه
نتنياهو مباشره مع انتهاء قمه العقبه قال
مباشره بانه بالنسبه للمستوطنات حسب جدول
الزمني المتبع الها قال انا الحاكم في
الضفه الفلسطيني وانا اقرر فيها بكفير قال
بشكل واضح انه ما يحصل في الاردن يبقى
بالاردن وبالتالي لا رجانات لدينا على
بيانات صدرت ان كان في عمان او في اي
منطقه اخرى نقول ان هذه خطوه هذه واجبات
القياده تتخذها في اتجاه صحيح في العمل
السياسي والدبلوماسي والتقدم كل مطالب
الشعب الفلسطيني ابتداء من الاسرى
المعتقلين او معتقلين حتى الان من مساله
1993 يعني ما قبل اتفاقيات اوسلو مرونه
بالمرضى انتهاءا بموضوع المسجد الاقصى
والتوهلات الاسرائيليه ووقف الاستيطان انا
بعتقد بانه هكذا في التل ابيب لن تتوقف عن
اجرامها ولا عن مشروعها الايدلوجي الطامح
الى طرد الفلسطيني حتى من الاردن ولكن
تجربتنا الاردن متفائل
الاردن متفائل بالنقاط التي تم الاتفاق
عليها على شرط ان تطبق هل هناك مؤشرات على
امكانيه تطبيق على الاقل ما يتعلق بالجانب
الامني وهو خفض التصعيد
جيد وهذا ما ورد في البيان انه يطالب دوله
الاحتلال ان تكون قولا وفعلا وليس فقط على
الورق ما جاء في بدايه البيان مباشره
اتفاق الطرفين على التنفيذ الاتفاقيات
السابقه ومن قال انه اسرائيل تستعد ان هي
تطبق هذا الاتفاقيات دعا الاخوه الاردن او
مصر او فلسطين اي احد يتفائل ونحن من حقنا
نتفاءل ولكن في ظل وجود حكومه فاشيه بهذا
الشكل واتلاف حكومي يقوم على طرد
الفلسطيني وتهجيرهم حتى تدمير الدوله
العبريه من الداخل واستمعت لضيفك قبل قليل
من تل ابيب كيف تحدث بهذه اللغه الواضحه
على نتنياهو وحكومه الفاشيه وبالتالي هذه
الحكومه ستذهب المنطقه الى حمام من الدم
وسكنه قال ايضا
بان نتنياهو معني بالتهدئه خاصه خلال فتره
شهر رمضان المبارك المقبل هل ايضا هل ايضا
الجانب الفلسطيني ونحن سمعنا موقف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه هل هو معني ايضا بالتهدئه في
هذه المرحله
شكرا لك السيد محمد المصري في رام الله
[موسيقى]
في موضوع اخر انسحاب من معاهده ستارت التي
تهدف للحد من الاسلحه النوويه ثم حديث عن
ضروره اخذ القدرات النوويه للدول
الاوروبيه الرائده في حلف شمال الاطلسي
بعين الاعتبار مواقفوا متتاليه تصب في
اتجاه واحد وهو تعالي نبره الحديث عن
احتمالات مواجهه نوويه بين روسيا والناتو
لا من جانب المراقبين وانما على لسان
الرئيس الروسي الذي يتهم الدول الاوروبيه
بمحاوله الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه ببلاده
تلويح بمواجهه ام استعداد للاسواق تصريحات
الرئيس الروسي بشان القدرات النوويه لدول
الناتو خصوصا بريطانيا وفرنسا تعيد الى
الواجهه احتمالات توسع المواجهه بين روسيا
ودول الحلف فالرئيس فلاديمير بوتين اتهم
الدول الرائده في الحلف برغبتها في الحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا وشدد على ضروره
اخذ قدراته النوويه بعين الاعتبار مشددا
على ان اخراج الحلف من معاهده ستارت كان
في سياق انفراج العلاقات ما يعني تغيرا في
مقاربه روسيا للنيتو الذي تقول انه لم يعد
منظمه سياسيه بل كتله عسكريه
جغرافيا حدود روسيا مع دول الناتو لا
تتجاوز سته في المئه من مجمل حدود روسيا
الا ان قبول عضويه السويد وفنلندا سيزيد
من ذلك وهو مصدر قلق بالغ وحساسيه شديده
بالنسبه لروسيا التي لها حدود مع اربع
عشره دوله خمس منها عضو في الحلف ولا يخفي
المسؤولون الروس توجزهم من تمدد الحلف
واقترابه اكثر من حدود بلادهم فحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا بنظر مؤيديها وقائيه لمنع
تمدد النيتو واقترابه اكثر وقبلها كانت
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في جورجيا سنه
2008 يزيد من حده هذه الهواجس ما اعلن عن
عدم ممانعه السويد وفنلندا تثبيت اسلحه
نوويه للنيتو على اراضيهما بعد تاكيد
انضمامهما وهو ما يعني تضييق الهامش
الزمني المتاح للروس للاستعداد ورغم ان
لدى روسيا كما تقول اكثر مما تملكه دول
النيتو مجتمعه في الرؤوس النوويه المحموله
على الصواريخ العابره للقارات الا ان
الحلف يتفوق على روسيا في الرؤوس النوويه
التي يمكن تحميلها على غواصات او التي
يمكن اطلاقها من الطائرات المقاتله
تشتد نبره التصريحات بين روسيا والغرب
ومعها يزداد تصعيد السياسات والمواقف
اخرها الانسحاب من معاهده ستارت وتحت يد
كل من الفريقين اسلحه دمار شامل
السيد فرانك المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات
العسكريه بجامعه
والضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه
بريطانيا مقصوده بكلام الرئيس بوتين عن
القدرات النوويه لدول حلف شمال الاطلسي هل
في رسالته تصعيدا نوويا بتقديرك
لا اعتقد انه
التصعيد ولكن ما يحاول ان يقوم به الرئيس
بوتين هو ان يذكر العالم ولكن ايضا الشعب
في داخل روسيا اذا ليس فقط الولايات
المتحده بل ايضا فرنسا وبريطانيا وهذا ما
اشلتم اليه في تقريركم اذا كل هذه الدول
يريد ان يحذرها طبعا بالنسبه الى بريطانيا
لم يشملها الاتفاق حيث انها رفعت
الرؤوس النوويه في السنين الاخيره اذا
اجابه عن سؤالكم هذا التصريح ليذكر العالم
بان روسيا تراقب عن كثب فرنسا وبريطانيا
بالاضافه الى الولايات المتحده هل يمكن
صرف هذا الكلام
والتصريح للرئيس الروسي عن القدرات
النوويه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في السياسه هل
يمكن ان يؤدي ربما الى
حماسيه ربما توقف الحرب في اوكرانيا بعد
مرور عام على انطلاقتها
لا اعتقد ذلك حيث ان الغرب النيتو
والحلفاء من مثل السويد وفنلندا على وجه
الخصوص لا يتاثرون
بذكر الاسلحه النوويه ولكن
رايي والراي عدد كبير من الناس هو انه اذا
ما وصل القتال الى مرحله
يهدد فيها الدوله الروسيه على سبيل المثال
شبه جزيره القرم عند ذلك يمكننا ان نرى
خطرا حقيقيا بان يحصل تصعيد معين بالتالي
هل ممكن ان تسمح دول الناتو بريطانيا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان تقوم فعلا
اوكرانيا بتهديد الاراضي الروسيه ومنها
شبه جزيره القرم لان الرئيس الاوكراني
يتحدث دائما عن استعاده شبه جزيره القرن
نعم هذا سؤال ممتاز بالفعل اعتقد ان هذا
التوتر هو حقيقيه واساسيه بين اهداف الغرب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلف شمال
الاطلسي والدول الاوروبيه من جهه
واوكرانيا من جهه اخرى في الحقيقه ليس
هناك حماسه من جانب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
باتجاه استعاده القرم من قبل اوكرانيا
وكما تفضلت هذا ما يكرره الرئيس الاوكراني
هذا في صلب الاهداف الاوكرانيه ولكن هذا
على نقيض الرؤيه الامريكيه اذا هناك
ضبابيه بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع ولكن في
القريب العاجل اعتقد انه يتعين على الدول
الغربيه ان توضح لاوكرانيا حدود الدعم
الذي يمكن ان تلقاه يكثر الحديث
والتقييمات الاستخباراتيه من ان الصين
تخشى من استخدام روسيا لسلاح نووي بالتالي
ما يدفعها ربما لتزويد روسيا بالسلاح وبعض
التقنيات كيف ترون هذا
نعم اعتقد ان هذا التحليل مثير للاهتمام
يمكننا ان ننظر اليه بطريقتين الطريقه
التي تفضلت بوصفها الصين طبعا هذه مصلحه
العالم ولكن ايضا الصين كما اشرت تقضي
بتفادي هذا المسار تفادي هذا المسار بشان
النزاع بين روسيا واوكرانيا ولكن هناك
طريقه اخرى لمقاربه الموضوع وهي انه كلما
طال امد الازمه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سوف تنظر باتجاه اوروبا عوضا عن
المنطقه
الاسيويه
ومنطقه المحيط الهادئ اذا اوروبا هي
الاولويه بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالتالي هناك توتر كبير على
مستوى الجيو السياسي ولكن التحليل الذي
تفضلت به اي مساعده
لروسيا هي لمساعده في هذا الاتجاه اعتقد
ان هذا التحليل هو شكرا لك
المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه بجامعه
والضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه
ميدانيا ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قوتها صدت واحدا 71 هجوم روسيا معظمها على
محاور القتال في اقليم دومباس الشرقيه
اوكرانيا خلال الساعات الاخيره واضافت
انها احبطت العديد من المحاولات الروسيه
للتقدم نحو مواقع قواتها في مدينه بخموت
وقالت مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان اعنف
المعارك تدور في المحور الشمالي لمدينه
مخموت كما وصفت الوضع على الضفه الشرقيه
لنهر بخموت بالحرج
في تطورات الجبهات كذلك قال المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه فاديمسكي ان
اوكرانيا ستكون مستعده للقيام بهجوم مضاد
في الربيع بهدف تحرير كل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم
واشار لنا التوقيت المحدد للهجوم المضاد
يعتمد على عوامل عده من ضمنها توريد
الاسلحه الغربيه واوضح المتحدث ان احد
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه سيكون محاوله ما
سماه دق اسفين في الجبهه الروسيه بالجنوب
بين شبه جزيره القرم والبر الرئيسي لروسيا
وقال المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه
ان الهجوم لن يتوقف قبل اعاده اوكرانيا
الى حدود عام
1991 ولم يستبعد ان تضرب اوكرانيا
مستودعات الاسلحه في الاراضي الروسيه لا
سيما في منطقه بيل قرود وقال ان الهجمات
على اوكرانيا ستبدا من هناك وان هذا يشكل
تهديدا على سبيل المثال
[موسيقى]
اتابع ما تداعيات الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
وشمال سوريا حيث حذر الدفاع المدني السوري
العامل في مناطق السيطره المعارضه من
كارثه حقيقيه في شمال غربي سوريا جراء
تفشي مرض الكوليرا بسبب الدمار الكبير في
البنيه التحتيه وشبكات المياه والصرف
الصحي كما افاد الدفاع المدني بان العديد
من المباني السكنيه والمدارس باتت تشكل
خطرا على المدنيين بسبب تصدعها جراء
الزلزال والهزات الارتداديه التي ضربت
المنطقه خلال الفتره الماضيه
معنا من البروكسل احمد عبد الرحمن مدير
العمليات في منظمه اطباء بلا حدود سيد عبد
الرحمن ما حجم القلق من تفشي الكوليرا في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه
القلق كبير يعني بصراحه لانه يعني الكارثه
اللي حصلت في سوريا هي الضخمه لكن هي اتت
يعني بعد حوالي اكثر من 12 سنه من من نزاع
المسلحه في المناطق عديده في سوريا ادى
للنزوح ضخم في سوريا يعني سوريا هي البلد
الاكبر حاليا في العالم من حيث عدد النزور
حيث العدد تقريبا 13 مليون نصفهم داخل
داخل سوريا
بالنسبه للنصف الموجود داخل سوريا وتعرض
لنزوح مستمر على مدى طويل والنزوح وعدم
وجود مرافق صرف صحي او مياه شرب امنه حتى
من قبل كارثه الزلزال كان هنالك تفشي
لاوبال كولر في شهر سبتمبر الماضي صحيح
كان هنالك اعلان لحاله الكوليرا فحاليا
يعني تضاعفت تضاعفت الماساه مع زياده حجم
النزوح حيث نزح اكثر من 180 الف فقط بعد
الزلزال فبالت الاعداد الضخمه هي بتضع ضغط
على على المرافق اللي هي اساسا محدوده
فبالتالي القلق كبير جدا
الضخمه سيد احمد ما الاولويه على المضى
القصير
بالنسبه لمرض الكوليرا ولا بشكل عام طبعا
بما انه الان يشكل تحدي اضافي عن التحديات
الموجوده اصلا
الاولويه بشكل الاولويه الاولى والقصوى هي
مياه شرب نظيفه يعني هذه الاولويه القصوى
الذي التي يجب يتم توفيرها في الوقت
الراهن والاولويه الثانيه المهمه هي دعم
المرافق الصحيه يعني نحن حاليا يعني
جابهتنا مشاكل عديده جدا لايصال
المستلزمات الطبيه بشكل سريع وعاجل لاعداد
ضخمه من المستشفيات
صحيه المتهدمه فبالتالي يجب ان تتوفر
مرافق صحيه مخصصه لعلاج مرض الكورونا حتى
لا يتم اختلاق الحالات ولازم تتوفر اعداد
ضخمه من الادويه الموقده للحياه والمحاليل
الوليديه لانه اذا تفشلوا مع الكوليرا في
في كذا اعداد يعني تظل تظل المعاناه
ما هي المعوقات امام ايصال هذه المساعدات
اذا
الثلاث المعابر المفتوحه ان احنا رسمنا في
اول اسبوعين بعد الزلزال متوسط حجم عدد
الشاحنات اللي عبرت من من تركيا الى سوريا
كالاقل من المتوسط 11 يوم في عام 22
فبالتالي حجم المساعدات رغم فتح المعامل
في الاسبوعين الاوائل كان بطيء وشحيح يعني
يعني حاليا في بعض الازدياد في حركه عبور
الشاحنات اطباء بلا حدود تمكنا من ايصال
اكثر من 14 شاحنه لكن يعني لا تزال هنالك
عدم انسيابيه بالنسبه للعبور وحجم
الاحتياجات هو الضخم جدا والاليه الامميه
الموجوده حتى الان في الوقت الراهن يعني
هي لم تستطع مجابهه الازياد الطارئه التي
حدثت في الفتره الاخيره وبالتالي لابد من
من زياده الانسيابيه بوصول المساعدات
الطبيه وغير الطبيه بشكل عادي شكرا احمد
عبد الرحمن مدير العمليات في منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود
[موسيقى]
سلطات التركيه في عدد من المناطق المنكوبه
الى حفر قبور جماعيه لدفن ضحايا زلزال
السادس من الشهر الجاري الذي ضرب جنوب
البلاد وعمد بعض اهالي الضحايا الى دفن
اسر بكاملها في قبر واحد في مشاهد مؤلمه
تعكس جانبا من الماسه
يا الله
[موسيقى]
لم تفتر الاحزان بعد وما زالت تعتصر
القلوب وجع
احوال الرعب التي عاشوها لم تمنحهم فرصه
دفن موتاهم كما اعتادوا فلجاوا الى دفنهم
في قبور جماعيه والهزات الارتداديه تتكرر
كانت ليله شديده البروده وكان الكل هائما
على وجهه لا يقوى على شيء اخرجنا الضحايا
من تحت الانقاض وبعضهم اخرج اشلاء اجتهد
البعض حينها وخاف من تكرار الامر او ترك
الضحايا دون دفن لائق فادفن عده اشخاص في
قبر واحد
لم يمهل الزلزال فرق الانقاذ كثيرا من
الوقت لذا سارعت الى حفر قبور جماعيه تم
ترميز من عرفت هوياتهم وكانت جثث مجهول
الهويه توضع في ثلاجه حفظ الموتى ليوم
واحد ومن لم يتعرف عليه احد دفن في مكان
خاص
في هذه الماساه قصص عن اسر كامله خطفها
الموت
مصطفى فقد ما يزيد عن 30 شخصا من افراد
اسرته استمرت عمليات انتشار جثثهم لاكثر
من اسبوع ودفن عدد منهم في قبر جماعي
عرفان من اللحظه الاولى ابن احفاد
خالصين وكنت راينا اول الجثث اللي طلعت
كانت ابن عم نوزه
خفت كل بصيص امل في العثور على ناجين وان
كانت السلطات لم تختم عمليات البحث
والانقاذ بعد في هاتاي
الامل الوحيد هو اخراج ما تبقى من جثث حتى
تلقى عليها نظره وداع اخيره وتحظى بمراسم
دفن لائقه لم يتمكن الذين فقدوا احبائهم
في هذه الكارثه من استيعاب ما جرى حتى
اليوم ورغم شعورهم بالاسى لكنهم يجدون
سلوى في قدرتهم على مباراه موتاهم الثرى
في حينما يزال اخرون ينتظرون انتشار جثث
من فقدوهم من تحت الانقاض عمر الحاجه
الجزيره من ولايه عطاي
[موسيقى]
وفي مقاسات اخرى وفي مكان اخر ارتفع عدد
غرق غرقا مركز طالبي لجوء قبل السواحل
الايطاليه الى 58 ونقلت وكاله روترز عن
مسؤولين ايطالي قوله ان الناجين من غرق
المركب قالوا انه كان يقل ما بين 140
راكبا و150 وفيما تعهدت رئيسه الحكومه
الايطاليه بوقف الهجره عبر البحر دعت
المفوضيه الاوروبيه للتوصل الى اتفاق جديد
بشان الهجره جاته قال مفوض الامم المتحده
السامي للهجره ان الوقت قد حان اتفاق بين
الدول على اتخاذ اجراءات لتجنب المزيد من
هذه الماسي
استنكرت منظمات حقوقيه تونسيه ما وصفته
بالخطاب التحريضي ضد المهاجرين الافارقه
من دول جنوب الصحراء بعد دعوه الرئيس قيس
سعيد الى التصدي لتدفق هؤلاء المهاجرين
نحو بلاده وقد تصاعدت حده الجدل حول ملف
المهاجرين الافارقه بعد التعرض عدد منهم
لمضايقات واعتداءات عنصريه
بين البحث عن رحلات طيران تعيدهم الى
اوطانهم او تجنب الظهور في الشوارع
والاحياء التي يقطنونها خوفا من المضايقات
والاعتداءات يتارجح وضع اغلبيه المهاجرين
من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء بعد خطاب
الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي ادعى فيه الى ضروره
وضع حد لتدفق اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء
المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى بلده
ابراهيم مواطن سنغاليون يقيم في تونس منذ
اكثر من عشر سنوات اختار ان يشارك احتجاجه
على ما توصف بالهجمه العنصريه ضد ابناء
الجاليه الافريقيه في تونس من خلال هذا
التحرك الذي دعت اليه منظمات حقوقيه
تونسيه
اعتقد ان رساله لم تمر بشكل جيد نعتبر
انفسنا في بلدنا هنا كما ان التونسيين
يعتبرون انفسهم في بلدهم عندما يكونون
عندنا ومرحبا بهم اعتقد ان الموضوع ادير
بطريقه سيئه
المنظمات الحقوقيه في تونس عبرت بدورها عن
استنكارها لتداعيات خطاب الرئيس على وضعيه
المهاجرين من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء في
تونس البالغ عددهم وفق احصائيات رسميه نحو
21 الف شخص لدى خطاب خطير وتلته اعتداءات
على اخوتنا في جنوب الصحراء وصل الاعتداء
على الحرمه الجسديه اعتداءات بالعنف طردهم
اليوم نشوفو حتى في مؤسسات يعني اليوم
مؤسسات تع نقل معلقين بلايك ملاي لاقتطاع
التذاكر تجرب اقتطاع تذاكر لفارقه من جنوب
الصحراء بعد الجدل الواسع الذي تلاه خطابه
وجد الرئيس قيس سعيد نفسه مضطرا لتقديم
توضيحات في اكثر من مناسبه بالتطبيق
القانون
يقال
ان هناك تمييز عنصري
تمييز
ضد الافارقه نحن دوله افريقيه ولكن هناك
مخطط للتوطين واشرت الى هذا بدورها لم
تنفي وزاره الداخليه ما راجع عن اعتقال
مئات المهاجرين من دول افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء خلال الايام الاخيره بسبب عدم
امتلاكهم وثائق اقامه قانونيه مؤكده في
الوقت ذاته عدم وقوع اي انتهاكات ضدهم
لا يلقى الموقف الرسمي بخصوص ملف
المهاجرين من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء في
تونس قبولا من المنظمات الحقوقيه بل انه
يصطدم بتحذيرات متواتره من مغبه تغذيه
خطاب التحريض والكراهيه وما قد ينجم عنه
من تداعيات امنيه واجتماعيه ميساء
الفطناسي الجزيره تونس
[موسيقى]
نعود لماساه غرق قارب المهاجرين والى
مسارات الهجره التي ترى المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره التابعه للمتحده ان البحر الابيض
المتوسط من اخطر طرقها في العالم فمنذ عام
2011 اصبحت ليبيا نقطه انطلاق رئيسيه
للمهاجرين الافارقه نحو اوروبا عبر
ايطاليا كما تكثفت الهجره من تونس عبر هذا
المسلك الاكثر فتكا بالمهاجرين قبل البحر
المتوسط تتعين على المهاجرين الافارقه قطع
مسافات طويله عبر الصحراء وصولا الى بلدان
شمال افريقيا رغم مخاطر الموت عطشا وعنف
المهربين وتجار البشر والعصابات المسلحه
في قاره امريكا تعتمد حركه الهجره على
شبكات مسارات لعل ابرزها الحدود بين
المكسيك والولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث
غالبا ما يحاول المهاجرون القادمون من
امريكا الوسطى والجنوبيه
الى الولايات المتحده بالاختباء في شاحنات
البضائع او سباحه عبر نهر ريو غراندي وفي
اسيا تشكل الطرق البحريه اهم مسالك
المهاجرين الروهينجا والبنغاليين في
المقام الاول عبر خليج البنغال وبحر
اندمان باتجاه البلدان المجاوره او حتى
لمحاوله الوصول الى اوروبا في نهايه
المطاف هناك طريق اخر في اسيا هو الحدود
بين ايران وتركيا التي شهدت تدفقا غير
مسبوقا للمهاجرين الافغان منذ تولي طالبان
السلطه في اغسطس من عام 2021 اما في
اوروبا فيعتبر بحر المانش او القبائل
الانجليزي اهم مسار للجوء املا في العمل
والاقامه في المملكه المتحده البريطانيه
تلك المسالك تعبرها سنويا اعداد هائله من
المهاجرين يموت كثير منهم قبل الوصول الى
وجهتهم وتقول المنظمات الدوريه للهجره ان
نحو خمسين الف مهاجر قضوا او فقدوا منذ
عام 2000 واربعه عشر خلال محاولتهم الوصول
الى وجهات كل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي من بين اولئك
الضحايا اكثر من
19500 شخص لقوا حتفهم في البحر المتوسط
خلال توجههم الى اوروبا وقد يكون العدد
اعلى من ذلك
في طريق الصحراء لقي اكثر من 5000 من
ابناء افريقيا جنوب الصحراء مصرعهم بين
عامي 2014
و20022 بسبب البيئه القاسيه واعمال
العصابات وقطاع الطرق وخلال الفتره نفسها
قضى اكثر من ثلاثه الاف مهاجر غرقا في نهر
ريو غراندي او اختناقا في شاحنات نقل
البضائع خلال محاولتهم عبور حدود المكسيك
باتجاه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ووفقا
للمنظمه التابعه للامم المتحده فانما
يناهز 5000 مهاجر في اسيا ماتوا او فقه
فقدوا خلال السنوات الثامن الماضيه معظمهم
من الرهنغيا وبنغلاديش لنفهم الوضع اكثر
ينضم الينا من واشنطن السيد جيسي ماركس
المسؤول في منظمه اللاجئين الدوليه
كيف تصف جهود احتواء اللاجئين
ثانكيو شكرا على المستوى الدولي وكل هذه
الطرق التي ذكرتموها في طرقكم يطرح السؤال
نفسه بغض النظر عن المحاولات او الحلول
يستمر او تستمر هذه الحركه حركه الهجره
التحديات خصوصا تلك التي شاهدناها اليوم
في ايطاليا هذه الماساه هي عباره عن تكرار
لنفسي القصص وهي تعكس الظروف الصعبه في
الساحل وفي الشرق الاوسط وفي افريقيا
وظروف تصبح اسوء وهذا ما يؤدي الى التركيز
على
الخطوط في منطقه الشرق الاوسط واراد
وافغانستان وخصوصا عندما ننتقل الى اشهر
الصيف هذه الطرق سوف تصبح اكثر اقتضاضا
وهذه
القصص سوف يزداد ويتعين على الدول
الاوروبيه والدول الاخرى ان تعمل على حلول
فعاله يجب ان نتذكر اننا نتحدث عن اناس عن
بشر نساء اطفال لديهم قصص وفي الماضي لقد
الطفل الكردي الذي وصل على على بعدما لفظه
البحر وهذا ادى الى ماساه حقيقيه تم
التسيط عليها تصيد ضوء عليها
دائما توجه انتقادات لان التركيز يكون
دائما لايجاد حلول
لمغادره اللاجئين مما تعرف بدول المغادره
بدل ايجاد حلول جذريه
فيما تعرف بدول المنشا كيف يمكن فعليا
الوصول الى وقف هذه الظاهره ظاهره اللجوء
غير النظامي وطبعا انت تشاهد يوميا عدد
القتلى في البحر والصحراء كما عرضنا في
التقارير الماضيه
اعتقد ان هذا السؤال ممتاز ما الذي يجب او
ما الذي يمكننا ان نقوم به الامم المتحده
يجب ان تعمل على دعم الاكثر الضعفا هناك
مشاكل مرتبطه بالحكومات القمع نقص الفرص
فرص الوظيفه والمدخول وفي الوقت نفسه نجد
النساء والاطفال والاقليات المحميه هذه
الاقليات التي تتعرض لمخاطر اكبر لذلك
يتعين على الامم المتحده ان تعمل مع الدول
في اوروبا بالاضافه الى الاماكن التي ياتي
منها هؤلاء والنقطه الثانيه هي ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يجب ان يعمل على قدراتي البحث
والانقاذ خصوصا في المناطق الاساسيه من
مثل المتوسط اذا الوضع الذي حصل اليوم في
ايطاليا هذه الامور يمكن ان نتفادها من
خلال تعزيز القدرات
الاساسيه لاستثمار بهذا الموضوع ثالثا
الاسره الدوليه تؤدي دورا اساسيا على
المستوى الجماعي وهناك ضروره للعمل في
شمال افريقيا وايضا في انظمه حمايه
للاجئين والمهاجرين
شكرا لك سيد الجاسي ماركس المسؤول في
منظمه اللاجئين الدوليه في واشنطن
[موسيقى]
الحق في وظيفه باجر جيد والحق في رعايه
صحيه جيده في تعليم جيد وفي سكن ميسور
التكلفه هي حقوق سلط عليها الضوء كتاب
جديد لعضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
تحت عنوان
او لا باس بان تكون غاضبا اذا الراسماليه
يضع سندس وهو شخصيه مؤثره يتخطى تاثيرها
حدود الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه
الحقوق ضمن حقوق الانسان الطبيعيه ويشدد
في كتابه على ان اي مواطن لا يمكنه ان
يكون حرا من دون ضمان الحد الادنى من
الحقوق الاقتصاديه صحيح ان كتاب ساندرز
وهو من ابرز شخصيات اليسار الامريكي
والحركه التقدميه يركز على الوضع في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وما اعتبره
انعداما للمساواه في المداخيل والثروات
يرى انه بات اكبر من اي وقت مضى لكن ما
جاء في الكتاب من افكار ودعوات للعداله
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه ينطبق بالضروره
على واقع مناطق كثيره عبر العالم والامل
كل الامل ان ينعم الجميع بحياه افضل في
ختام حصاد هذه الليله لكم وقفه رياضيه مع
لؤي محمود الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته